nous sommes avec jérôme marty médecin et
président de l'union française pour une
médecine à libre remarqué bonjour et
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors vous avez vous même un été menacée
de mort à plusieurs reprises depuis
qu'en faites-vous l'objet de ces menaces
ça fait plusieurs mois que ça dure
plusieurs mois sa ré commencé avec les
la question des masques avec donc des
mouvements anti masqué qui était qui
menaçaient les les médecins qui disait
répété lundi qu'il fallait porter les
masques et pourquoi il fallait porter
des masques et puis ensuite vous avez la
campagne de vaccination qui est arrivé
les mouvements anti box et les menaces
qui ont émané de ceux de ce secteur-là
avec souvent effectivement des
structures qui instrumentalisent des
jeunes comme tel et fragilisés par la
crise et qui parce qu'ils sont
fragilisées par la crise souvent ont
besoin de boucs émissaires
à votre avis quelles sont les raisons de
cette violence envers le corps médical
qui se trouve en première ligne dans
cette crise sanitaire
la raison c'est que la crise a duré
depuis est dure maintenant depuis ta 6e
n'ont que durant depuis deux ans elle a
provoqué les dégâts et les freins à
sociaux des fracas économique des fracas
sanitaires très important des gens ont
tout perdu dans la crise où un tel
avenir qui leur paraît extrêmement
boucher sanofi puisse avoir la semaine
celui ci et on a transformé rapidement
la cause 70 des conséquences en cause
c'est à dire que les médecins soient les
conséquences de la crise sont bien
navrant parce que la piste des
sanitaires et une crise de défaut sont
honorés les militaires craignent en
avant là ce sont les médecins et on a
transformé
si jal là en gauche de la crise d'ado
fini personnes finissent par se dire
mais si on allait là c'est à cause des
médecins
la médiatisation des professionnels de
santé que l'on voit maintenant
pratiquement tous les jours sur les
plateaux de télévision at-elle amplifié
le phénomène selon vous elle a amplifié
le phénomène ce sens elle a mis en avant
un certain nombre de personnalités et
que j'ai encore une fois un certain
nombre d'organismes on a pu voir des
journaux ou des structures qui s'appelle
le jour l'eau qu'ils n'ont pas
emile qui s'appelle journaux on a pu
voir des sites qui sont répétés à
l'extrême droite publier des articles
qui sont de véritables appels à la
violence envers les mères les quais de
seine parce que ces structures là ont
intérêt à gêner le gouvernement
d'instituer ont intérêt à ce que on ne
résolvent pas ou on raisonne bien cette
crise et à ce moment là on cible ces
métiers là nous faisons des articles
totalement diffamatoires et mensongers
sur eux
mais ok monter en ligne encore une fois
des gens qui sont fragilisés qui parce
qu'ils sont pas utilisés ont tendance à
croire ce qu'on leur dit et a ciblé si
l'on à l'agressivité sur les réseaux
sociaux qui augmente vous en appelez à
olivier ferrand le ministre de la santé
et jean castex le chef du gouvernement
pour prendre des mesures quelles
pourraient être ces mesures déjà on est
étonné de pas avoir eu deux auditions
publiques là dessus avec la presse s'est
fait courser menaces reçues par les
professionnels de santé maintenant
depuis plusieurs semaines beaucoup de
médias nationaux oublier cela et l'on
s'étonne de ne pas avoir pu de position
publiques émanant du gouvernement ou
émanant du cosl de l'ordre des médecins
pour rappeler la gravité de tels faits
pour rappeler que les gens qui ceux qui
se permettent de faire ce genre de
choses peuvent être sanctionnés très
lourdement
voilà c'est juste juste rappeler cela
rappelait que l'on ne peut pas
impunément comme ça menacer des blouses
blanches qui sont là juste pour soigner
des malades et pour faire que l'on
puisse sortir le plus rapidement
possible de cette crise est ce que les
médecins visés par ces
menacé vous même avait porté plainte oui
on nous vole moi je porte plainte
systématiquement et on conseille aux
médecins de systématiquement déposé une
main courante à faire une déclaration
pharos saisir leurs ordres et se
rapprocher leurs syndicats si nous avons
peur ou deux syndicats s'ils ne l'ont
pas systématiquement il faut répondre
comme cela ne pas laisser les choses
simplicité on le sait jamais ce qui peut
se passer donc il faut jouer toujours
signalé jérôme marty médecin et
président de l'union française pour une
médecine et merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce matin